the jurogan experience i used to
actually could touch the rim
i almost dunk but my knees was like yo i
don't care what you put on them fam
we ain't doing it did you see the tom
sagura dunk
you didn't see what happened no oh i
gotta show you something
tom seguro went to dump dunk and as he's
running
towards the net he blows out his patella
tendon
as he's leaping up in the air his knee
blows out and then he falls
and lands on his arm snaps his arm in
half so he blew out his knee and his arm
all in one terrible maneuver
and they did it all on video him and
bert were having a dunk competition
and now tom has uh he's got this thing
on his
his hand because his nerves got damaged
and he's watch this
no no he's not okay watch this boom look
at the arm breaks
[Music]
his arms his arms
not good that's why it's good to be a
little athletic
because occasionally you and your stupid
friends want to have like
a ridiculous competition for a video
this is the
this that's the reason why wives yell at
husbands
no don't go are you going to play
basketball again
like but that's not even regular
basketball they're just they were just
dunking over and over and over again
so um i'm quite sure you know bill
bellamy
sure so bill bellamy's um
road manager terrance they're shooting
just shooting around in the gym just
shooting regular shooting
and it's always this man you need man
pull up on you on your toes lift up on
your toes
and shoot the ball so he lifts up on his
toes and blows out whatever's back there
is it's gone achilles he's achilles oh
no that's a bad one like yo i'm like see
like don't listen to people when you're
just shooting around
just listen to yourself just i'm just
going to do this
i'm just going to lay the ball up not
don't if something like ah
that's why when i go to the gym i
intentionally put on cowboy boots
[Laughter]
intentionally i'm like cowboy boots and
shorts for me man
i don't want nobody trying to convince
me to do anything i'm like no i'm not
doing it
yeah i remember the last time i was
convinced i'm not doing it
what was what convinced you the last
time oh
hey man first it always start with
you play football didn't you
that i think it's been more injuries
started with that right there so you
play football so
i'm like yeah we you know we all play
football
so me my friends we out there in dress
shoes mind you oh no
andre we supposed to be running one
little quick little route this way
nope nope out we outside the gym because
it's the only place where
it's called like it's no cars like yo we
go right here to la fitness
like but why like why do you know where
l.a fitness is right now like why do you
even know
how first of all how does he even start
he's like yo
you going go to la finney now we out
there just throwing the ball
nerf ball not even a real football nerf
you know that's what he had in his car a
little nerf
with a little with the little um i think
they got some new ones where
they twist or something because my nerf
balls were smooth this was
has little waves in it throwing about
and i cut
forgetting that i have on dress shoes
because now you're getting competitive
one person catch the ball see that's
touchdown first of all you know we're
close to
first of all there's okay if that's the
poll down there you're nowhere close to
it sir
so now now it's competitive now now up
on the line you know
now you really being what you saw on tv
now you've been to safety
and i cut i cut that dress shoe that
he'll
call a little gravel and it's hard to
explain
the side of your face being scratched up
like you
because the gravel scratch it's like
when like falling off a motorcycle and
you get the
the cement rash so i'm just like the
side of my face is scratched up my hand
is scratched up and i'm like
huh okay now i got to go home and
explain why my face is bleeding
you supposed to be at the club sir how
did how did you go from the club
to this okay let me tell you what
happened
okay we were drinking and someone said
you played football didn't you and
then all of a sudden you in the la
fitness you know
gym parking lot throwing a nerf ball
with dress shoes on the dress shoes on
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data
cost all for free spotify is absolutely
free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience